fundamentally the question is this
you've got a message that you want to
send and it's either yes or no or
sometimes in signaling they call it
knowledge and not acknowledge I can
access and no it's all very well but
then I get damaged they might get
corrupted coding theorists in the very
simplest case did realize that in order
to correct an error just a one bit error
you needed to repeat it three times on
computer file here we have talked about
this stuff in more detail I want to try
and keep this as accessible as possible
for people who are just coming at this
for the first time and try and explain
what it is about these three bit codes
that make sizes so much easier and the
Alpha my friends live in putting them a
diametrically opposite corners of a cube
what you're saying is if you send three
zeros that's fine if you send three ones
they don't get corrupted that's fine
just look how far away they are from
each other it doesn't matter how you get
from there to there all backwards you
have to go one two three
so that's technically called the
distance between these two code words so
there's two buzz phrases straightaway
code words and distance between them if
you on either side of these accurate
code words you write in what you might
get if one of the bits gets corrupted
and flipped you now have a situation
where if you receive 0 1 0 the answer is
sometimes called majority logic the
overwhelming decision at this point is
that it's got two zeros and one one so
therefore if you're going to correct it
it's far better to correct it to three
zeroes going down one edge than to try
and go all the way around the cube and
correct it to that we're using a total
of three bits like 1 1 1 3 this but the
actual message we're trying to get
across is yes or no a corn AK 0 or 1 so
of those 3 bits the only bit that counts
of a message is concerned is just one of
those bits however in the course of
keeping these code words far apart we
have agreed they are distance three from
one another in terms of a walk you do
around the cube along the edges so here
we are total number of bits number of
those bits per two devoted to the real
message only one
how many journeys around sides of the
cube would you have to take to get from
one code word into another so it's a
three one three code three one three is
the simplest
full Hamming code and it is perfect
what I mean by saying it is perfect
every single corner or eight of them
serves the purpose a corner is either a
code word the actual thing you're trying
to get through and hope it doesn't get
damaged or if it's not a code word it's
a correction vector it's a corner of the
cube that's adjacent which gives you the
clue that if you get fat received you go
to the nearest code word along a cube
edge so every single corner is concerned
with either the proper message or how to
correct it nothing goes to waste 3 1 3
mmm where do you think the next one of
these perfect ones would occur that
occupy all the corners not on a cube is
tiling let's be on a hypercube
so hypercube is going to have what
another for another well it'll be on at
all it could be a four-dimensional
hypercube of side damaged a little off
with a hammer I think I feel like it's
gonna be a round number to go four six
six one something close it's not I will
reveal the answer and then we'll try and
justify later on that's the simplest
proper Hamming code next for Hamming
code is not at six it's at seven and in
this notation
is this prime number related debt no
it's not a Z prime number related but
you will see a pattern emerging this
right hand thing of three is always
there even if you're on a hypercube you
keep your cool words three edges apart
and what happens with more bits in use
is you can afford more bits to hold the
message whereas before we had a one bit
message two possibilities here we've got
a 4 bit message which equates to 16
possibilities 16 possible code words 2
to the power 4 all wrapped up in a 7-bit
message now your final clue the next one
after this 15 11 3 there is a pattern
emerging here folks particularly on that
leading digit 3 7 15 always one less
than a power of 2 that's a necessary
condition together with systems 3
between code words that needs to be
proper for Hamming code and what I'm
saying to you is 7 4 3 is also perfect
let's try and reason wise perfect by
waving our hands around a lot ok it goes
like this you've got four code words
there on 7-dimensional hypercube it is a
seven dimensional hyper cube out of
every code word corner there are try and
imagine it seven edges going out
correction points for it
plus the corner itself so some plus 1 is
8 right you've got 8 possible things
that either the thing itself or its
correction points every code word counts
8 in terms of corners of the hypercube
but how many of these code words can you
have 2 to the power 4 is 16 and everyone
takes up a corner 16 times 8 is 128 will
you agree actually
darling you need 128
corners just by reasoning from a cube
right up to a seven dimensional hyper
cube you can say you would occupy 128
corners but consider seven bit codes
which is what we're talking about in
this hyper space what's - 2028 bingo so
you've got 128 corners and they are
exactly used up that is what a perfect
code is all about it's about using up
the corners on your hypercube to the
absolute maximum it's so eco friendly
you know absolutely nothing goes to
waste the big problem with these Hamming
codes is that they only correct one
error that is the stopper in the end
that they're just not suitable for the
kinds of situations that occur in real
life already out in noisy Wi-Fi setups
or out in interplanetary space very
comparable really in terms of background
noise bursts of horrible you know
activity going on there ruin your code
you need something rather more robust
than a code that can detect only one
error but nevertheless as a thing to
learn about first and the ability to
entirely cover certain hypercubes with
the codes and the way to correct them
they're very nice I'm very fond of
perfect code does this mean that other
codes in between these are unusable no
are those in the devil we've done one
already
we used Richard Hammonds methodology to
develop it but we didn't admit to its
shortcomings right